I know the sky is falling outside you
know is this falling and I get that and
the fans are real unjustice a bit but
you know we were going down to Dallas
and our guys are gonna be ready to play
and we're gonna win that football game
and when we do we're in first place in
the NFC ES we control our own destiny
we're right where we need to be that's
Doug Peterson coach of the Philadelphia
Eagles on WIP radio on Monday morning
and he said we're gonna win it kind of
got slipped in there Chris but it was
unmistakable Doug Peterson making it
clear that the Eagles are gonna win and
I appreciate that Doug because we're
doing a bad job Chris of picking the
games on Sunday night I'm glad that
there's a time machine involved here the
Doug Peterson gonna let us know who to
pick so we get this week's right oh yeah
yes seriously you know I appreciate this
aspect about Doug Peterson I mean he
instill instills confidence and the rest
of his football team you know we just
talked about it a few minutes ago I mean
it was I think a big reason of their
Super Bowl run a few years back his
ability to have the guts to go for it in
some big situations and rattly his team
around him and I think this is another
one of those moments you know I think
the team's probably doubting themselves
a little bit right now the way they got
beat by Minnesota up in Minnesota this
past weekend he knows maybe they need a
little something like this to back them
into the corner hey coaches still got
confidence in us he'll probably say
something tomorrow morning and address
it and the team meeting you know and and
and make it a little bit of a rallying
cry and the players will back him
because they don't want him to be wrong
here's the problem that yeah for as much
as we like what Doug Peterson had to say
on WIP yesterday when he just casually
in nonchalantly said we're gonna win he
was asked about it later in the day at
his regular Monday press conference and
he backtracked a little bit here's
Peterson with the media yesterday
afternoon never said guarantee when I'd
never do that temperature when he came
radio you said we're gonna go down there
when it games you regret just the way
you phrased it or no because I again it
shows confidence in our football team
and I promise you you know Jason
Garrett's gonna say the same thing with
it with his team they're gonna win the
football game as well and you know I'm
not gonna stand up here and go or go on
record and say we're gonna go down there
and try to win a game you know or we're
gonna ban hope hopefully we can go win
this you know I mean it just doesn't
show confidence I get that yeah it's a
tough needle for him to thread though
hey we're gonna win the game so you
guarantee it no but we're gonna win so
you guarantee it
no but we're gonna win I just I mean
that word guarantee I think for my
generation and Peterson's generation it
means a lot more because it all goes
back to Joe Namath yeah sure great I get
and that was like hallowed ground for 25
years like I don't think between Joe
Namath and Superbowl three and Mark
Messier in the 1994 championship run
right that it was like you never
guaranteed anything right and then after
Messier did it it's like I you're just
willy-nilly guarantee who cares it's not
like they're gonna come throw me in jail
if it's wrong but I think that's why
Peterson that's they I'm trying to
reconcile what seems irreconcilable
we're gonna win the game so you
guarantee it no but we're gonna win the
game it's just it's kind of comical and
yeah you want to show confidence but I
mean back it up you're saying we're
gonna win the game yeah yeah we're gonna
win the game all right we're gonna win
the game and if you don't all right we
didn't win the game I was wrong so what
yeah well I think there is a little bit
of a difference I mean he it wasn't like
he just it was a one statement I
guarantee we're gonna win the game and
that's it like and then you walk off the
podium like it was more about AI you
know you heard what he said a they I
know this the the the the the sky is
falling and you know everybody's
panicked here in Philadelphia and the
fans are all worried and all that what
we're gonna go down there and win a game
and my you know Dallas he's it wasn't a
guarantee I think the deal I think that
I think the kind of deadpan nonchalant
delivery made it even more impactful
like it's a given like why even bother
to guarantee it it's it's it's factual
you're gonna win yeah I you know I don't
have any problem with it now Dallas is
certainly gonna take it and and try to
use it as motivation on their own side I
mean they are there's no doubt that'll
be something that's
problem with it that that's exactly the
problem was saying that publicly and
it's just weird after a week in
Philadelphia where we saw Zach Brown who
just been cut by the Philadelphia Eagles
talk about we you know Kirk Cousins
whatever he basically talked trash about
Kirk Cousins and said he can't beat us
and then you know Kirk Cousins torched
his butt out there on Sunday and you
know that's where it's a little bit
weird to just the timing of the ball but
I don't think Doug Doug Peterson was
saying it to make a headline or do
anything like that I really do think he
was just kind of saying like a course
yeah we're gonna win I believe we're
gonna win he's got to think that way
that's the way football coaches our
players are their machines but here's
the thing and I think we're done we're
drilling down to the problem here you
have to think that but when you say it
you do give the other team something and
you know coaches and players all the
time oh we don't pay any attention to
the noise yes you do they do pay
attention to noise I mean you've got
Richard Sherman who is angrily and
defiantly insisting that reporters who
wrote the 49ers off before the season
continue to say those things because
they want to have the bulletin board
material yeah they want it they don't
want to hear how great they are they
want to hear how bad they are because
you take that and use it as motivation
you take Doug Peterson saying the Eagles
are gonna win as motivation and the
motivation manifests itself Chris not
just in what you do on game day I firmly
believe this and you tell me if I'm
wrong when you've got extra motivation
leading into a game that means on
Tuesday you're gonna do everything you
need to do to have the best possible
Tuesday of game week that you can have
whether you're rehabbing studying film
studying a game plan
you're gonna lock in you're gonna dial
in you need to be hydrated you're gonna
be hydrated you need to avoid that
doughnut you're going to avoid that
doughnut you need to get your lift in
you're gonna bust your ass in the weight
room to get your lift in it leads into
Wednesday same thing it's actus I mean
you're more focused you're more locked
in you're more dialed in and then when
sunday rolls around you're better
equipped to win the game and that
motivation that extra little kick in the
butt that you got from that statement
that someone made is the thing that
caused you to push all the cobwebs out
and the week in and week out grind of
the NFL and do everything you need to do
to get yourself ready to win that's
where I believe the bulletin board
material has it's big
no mic III your you're a hundred percent
right you're right yeah I mean you know
just moments where I've been through
that and might whether it was college
the NFL even high school yeah you use it
as food fuel as you're sitting there
putting your pads on getting ready to go
out to practice somebody will make a
comment and you know everybody's like
yeah he did say that let's you know
screw that guy let's go the other side
of that story is though you know
Philadelphia is the ultimate you know
we're backed into in a corner and watch
out whether it was a Superbowl run or
what we saw last year it will rally
their team as well to where they're
gonna go we want to make our coach look
right here and it's gonna and it's gonna
put pressure on him to cuz you know he's
white writing you know writing checks
with his mouth that his butt can't cash
there so where he's gonna go and go okay
yeah maybe I have a little bit little
pressure on myself I might have to come
up with you know five or six plays the
design this week just to screw doubtless
over just to make sure you know I don't
seem like an idiot here when it's all
said and done or people try to reignite
this conversation so there is that side
of it as well where it'll motivate the
team that has said it especially when
it's a coach you know coming out and
saying it that way and a coach that's
well respected by his team at that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports